i think really the scary thing about
abuse
is that the reason it takes years for
people to come out
is because so often they don't even know
that's what it was and for me
it was like as soon as i knew
that was what had happened like my first
thought was
holy crap there's other people who don't
know and
that also explains why you wanted back
on the team right which is
part and parcel of nike's big defense
and all of this like what do you mean
she's saying all this stuff she was
trying to get back on the team
so right so this is so
well salazar gets banned in september of
2019
right so does that report come out in
advance of that or do those
things they came out at the same time
same moment and then like six weeks
later the new york times piece came out
right and it was the longest six weeks
of my life
so there's a good like three year period
where you go from being mary kane
fastest girl in america bright future
you know olympic glory is a foregone
conclusion for this person there was
even a new york times article about you
like in 2015 right
which was a whole glorious picture
you're like whitewashing this whole
experience
but then there's this period where you
disappear
right it's like what happened to mary
kane like she just vanished off the
landscape you go home
you're trying to piece yourself back
together during this period of time it's
like this fallow era where
suddenly you're nowhere to be found
then so you're dealing with what you're
dealing with and trying to
come to terms with this but still buying
into all of it thinking you're going to
make your way back
right until this report comes out and
like i'll say this right so i
you know was like i'm not tough enough
like i can't handle it
like i i'm maybe not like built to be a
pro right
and what ended up happening was i kind
of had this like
um like injury and
again my parents like my coach john
nobody like i hadn't really shared a lot
of these stories with
um there was maybe like inklings of it
and pieces of it
but like like with everything you're
just
like if i can't even look back on that
like how could i share that with
somebody else
and so um you know around
like probably like in the beginning of
that year it was like
maybe 2018 summer um alberto and i had
talked like once
and it was kind of meant for me to be my
like closure moment of being like
okay and are you still you're still
getting paid by nike though
throughout this period um yeah i was
still i yeah i
my contract ended december 31st 2018. so
i was still a nike athlete
so it wasn't like weird in a way that
there was like that kind of moment and
then kind of
between then and when i was maybe hurt
at the beginning of 2019 um
like he kind of kept like reaching out
to my coach just see like how am i doing
like you know like friendly stuff i
think okay we're
we're fine right and then you know
i was i got hurt we asked like oh any
tips
i ended up going out to portland and for
me
a lot of it was like i again i still had
this like
you know i felt so bad about everything
that had happened
and i talked very openly
with alberto about the fact that like
you know i developed like a really
serious eating
you know um disordered eating and i i
use the word disordered eating instead
of eating disorder because
i wasn't bulimic and i wasn't anorexic
um you know in terms of the like true
clinically diagnosed definition
but i under it substantially and i was
underweight
a lot and i went through like big
fluctuations and i would try to purge
and i wouldn't be successful um so
it's kind of more within that like
disordered eating bucket
um but i you know i shared this
and it was kind of like okay
like god just not like acknowledged and
i think that was kind of like a little
bit like uh
like wow like i guess like
i guess that's
like to me i think at the time it was
almost this like
yeah yeah we like yeah you weren't you
couldn't handle it
you know and i think that so in his in
other words
in other words sorry to interrupt you in
other words in his mind
you being a product and not a person
he'd already made the decision
that you were damaged goods yeah and
it's like oh that's fine you can come
and tell me that but like i already knew
this wasn't gonna work
out and i've moved on totally and so
you're kind of like okay
like cool but like you know i'm still
like trying to try and be a pro whatever
but i'm at that point like pretty like
okay
this like you're maybe like start like
that first
crack in the rose-colored glasses is hit
right
and up until then nobody had ever hit
the glasses right i've just been going
through life being like that whole
situation was
totally normal because everybody who was
out there with me
acted like it was totally okay and i'm
too embarrassed to tell
almost people in my life who maybe would
tell me that it wasn't
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
you